колеги
Схаменіться Ну що ви робите ну зараз до
нас звернулися посли Великої сімки Да
може подобатись не подобатись Але ж ми
їх просимо б за гроші ми ж до них Ідемо
І кажемо Сполучені Штати Америки дайте
нам грошей Канада дайте нам грошей
Великобританія Франція Японія дайте нам
грошей а далі Німеччина дайте нам грошей
а далі а далі вони звертаються до нас
позавчора всі посли це спільна позиція
говорять не призначайте нових членів
рахункової палати до прийняття нового
Закону тому що вони хочуть знати що їхні
гроші порахують вони відповідають перед
платником податків з США з Франції з
Німеччини щоб нам віддати їхні кошти
щоби ми тут відбудовувалися збереглися А
ми що говоримо нам наплівать Ду Що
робите взагалі Нащо це робити а далі Ми
вийдемо і скажемо А ви знаєте в нас
проблеми в Сполучених Штатах ай-айяйяй
як виходить А ви знаєте в нас проблеми в
Євросоюзі ай-ай-яй Які Так це ж ганьба
якась далі буде виходити президент і
казати яні тряпка Нащо це все Чому ви
просто нехтуєте тими людьми кого ми же
просимо ну це одно ви йдете як людини і
кажете допоможіть мені вам говорять
добре Ми допоможемо Але ми хочемо бачити
як ти витрачаєш ці кошти а ти кажеш Да
пошли ви да це що ж взагалі таке друзі
Схаменіться не робіть цього не
протягуйте просто щоб зробити головою
рахункової палати цю піщанську наближену
до родини зеленських на її сестру
оформлена Віла роди Нащо це все робити
буде чергова ганьба
зупиниться